le Qatar tel qu'il veut qu'on le voit
l'amour du ballon rond l'emporte sur la
politique pour les centaines de milliers
d'amateurs venus rêver de remporter
cette Coupe du monde
[Musique]
la fête ne prend jamais de pause
les partisans de toutes les nationalités
fraternisent beaucoup sont étonnés de
leur expérience en tout cas en Europe on
entendait beaucoup de choses négatifs
sur le Qatar sur l'organisation sur sur
les esprits assez renfermés ici alors
que dès qu'on arrivait c'est pas du tout
le cas les capteurs étaient très
accueillants l'hospitalité était
vraiment incroyable des partisans non
intimidés par l'interdiction de vendre
d'alcool dans les stades il trouve
d'autres endroits où ils peuvent boire
comme partout dans le monde il y a des
restos des barques qui forcer votre même
dans les fans les fans les fans
de nombreuses partisanes se disent aussi
agréablement surprise en autant qu'elle
respecte les nombreuses règles dont
celle sur le code vestimentaire
comme on a les s'habiller même si on est
de confession musulmane on s'est demandé
quand même est-ce que ici on pouvait
être libre à venir seul parce que je
suis venue seule elle aussi donc on se
posait beaucoup de questions mais
finalement ça se passe très très bien
être ici comme visiteur puis travailler
ici ça serait de différentes choses
alors selon moi si j'avais le choix je
ne choisirais pas kata pour comme une
femme pour travailler ici parce que il y
a beaucoup de choses genre
voter puis l'accès à l'éducation les
étrangers résidentes au Qatar profitent
de l'esprit festif temporaire en raison
du Mondial
des milliers de dollars pour pouvoir
vivre l'expérience de la Coupe du monde
dans leur cas l'opération séduction du
Qatar semble avoir fonctionné ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada